A quick warning-- there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of this show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
一个小小的警告——今天的节目中包含未经消音的脏话。如果你更喜欢消音版，可以在我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 上找到。
OK, before you can understand how Bob's sister became the talk of the third grade and the big day that that led to that people still remember, I need to explain first that Bob's sister is a drawing. The teacher in this third grade class, Mr. Ablao, spotted it one day while teaching math. He saw one of the students, Antonio, working on a picture.
好了，在了解鲍勃的妹妹是如何成为三年级学生谈论的焦点，以及那一天发生的事为何至今仍被人铭记之前，我得先解释一下，鲍勃的妹妹其实是一幅画。三年级班主任阿布劳（Mr. Ablao）老师在教数学时偶然发现了它。他看到一名叫安东尼奥的学生正在画这幅画。
I went over to him and said, put the picture away. I probably did that two or three times. And then the fourth time I went over, and I just took the picture and said, pay attention. It's math class. And I put it on my desk. He came up right before recess and is like, can I have my picture back? And I was like, what is this picture of anyways? And he said, it's Bob's sister. And I'm like, who's Bob sister? It turns out Bob's sister is a minion, which I don't even think Bob's sister exists in the minion world.
我走过去对他说，把画收起来。我可能说了两三次。第四次走过去时，我直接拿走画说，专心点，这是数学课，然后把它放在我的桌上。他在课间休息前走过来问，我能拿回我的画吗？我说，这画的到底是什么？他说，是鲍勃的妹妹。我说，鲍勃的妹妹是谁？原来鲍勃的妹妹是一个小黄人，我甚至不觉得小黄人世界里有鲍勃的妹妹这个角色。
You're saying the minions from the movie, Despicable Me?
你是说电影《神偷奶爸》里的小黄人？
Yes, exactly.
对，没错。
And he had just invented a sister character for Bob?
他只是凭空创造了一个鲍勃的妹妹角色？
Yeah, apparently.
是的，显然是这样。
Mr. Ablao taped the drawing to the bookshelf behind his desk, near a photo of a wolf that was already there. Because it was clear if Antonio kept the drawing, it would continue to be a distraction to him and a couple of his friends, who, at that point, were the only ones in class who really cared about Bob's sister.
阿布劳老师把这幅画贴在办公桌后的书架上，就在一张狼的照片旁边。因为很明显，如果安东尼奥一直拿着这幅画，它会继续让他和几个朋友分心，当时也只有他们几个真正关心鲍勃的妹妹。
I was like, don't worry. She's not going anywhere. She'll be right here. Any time you want to see her, she'll be behind me.
我说，别担心。她哪儿也不会去。她就在这儿。任何时候你想看她，她都会在我身后。
Because the kids were into the picture of Bob's sister.
因为孩子们都沉迷于鲍勃的妹妹这张画。
Yeah, and I didn't really quite understand why. I never investigated why this picture was such a big deal. But yeah, they would talk about it. They would go up and look at it. And yeah, it was a thing.
是的，我真的不太明白为什么。我从来没去探究为什么这张画这么重要。但确实，他们会谈论它。他们会走过去看它。它确实成了一个话题。
Why were you guys so excited about Bob's sister, do you think?
你们觉得为什么会对鲍勃的妹妹这么兴奋？
I think it's because it was another distraction in class that people could talk about.
我觉得是因为它是班里另一个可以讨论的话题，让人分心。
That's straightforward enough. This is Dylan, one of Antonio's friends, who was into Bob's sister from the start.
这话说得够直接。这是迪伦，安东尼奥的朋友，从一开始就迷上了鲍勃的妹妹。
Describe the drawing.
描述一下那幅画。
It's just like an octopus. And then it had two eyes and then tentacles coming out of it.
它就像一只章鱼。有两只眼睛，还有伸出来的触手。
I didn't realize Bob's sister was an octopus?
我居然不知道鲍勃的妹妹是只章鱼？
Bob's sister was an octopus.
鲍勃的妹妹就是只章鱼。
But Bob's a minion.
但鲍勃是个小黄人。
Well, it didn't really have anything to do with that.
嗯，这其实和那没什么关系。
And was he referring to the minion, Bob, or am I just--
他指的是那个叫鲍勃的小黄人，还是我——
No, he was not.
不，他不是指那个。
I see. Was it a good drawing?
我明白了。画得好吗？
It was like an eight-year-old's OK drawing. It wasn't amazing, but it was like, you knew what it was.
就像八岁孩子画的一样，还凑合。不算惊艳，但你知道它画的是什么。
This whole question-- is it an octopus, is it a minion-- I asked Antonio, who drew Bob's sister, about that. He tended to see Bob's sister as a Pac-Man ghost with big eyes, but he said-- and I thought this was surprisingly mature for somebody in elementary school. He thought part of the appeal of Bob's sister was that it was open to interpretation.
关于它是章鱼还是小黄人的问题，我问过画出鲍勃妹妹的安东尼奥。他倾向于把鲍勃的妹妹看作一个长着大眼睛的吃豆人幽灵，但他补充说——我觉得对于小学生来说这非常成熟——他认为鲍勃的妹妹之所以吸引人，是因为它可以有不同的解读。
I really don't know what it is. It's a thing. I don't know what it-- it's lots of different things. You could think of it as a minion that looks weird. You could think of it as Fly Guy with no legs. You could think of it as Pac-Man ghost with big eyes. Bob's sister was different to everybody. We never went with one of them. We didn't say anything. Anyone could believe what they want.
我真的不知道那是什么。它就是一个东西。我不知道它是什么——它有很多种可能性。你可以把它想成是一个长相古怪的小黄人。可以想成是没腿的《小飞侠》（Fly Guy）。可以想成是长着大眼睛的吃豆人幽灵。对每个人来说，鲍勃的妹妹都是不一样的。我们从未固定过一种说法。我们什么也没说。任何人都可以相信他们想相信的。
But the thing that was key to Bob's sister was, Bob's sister wasn't actually anyone's sister.
但鲍勃的妹妹最关键的一点是，她实际上并不是谁的妹妹。
Its name was just Bobsister, no space.
它的名字就叫 Bobsister（鲍勃妹妹），没有空格。
That's really funny.
这太搞笑了。
And we didn't come up with a gender either.
而且我们也没设定性别。
So Bobsister, gender unspecified, lived on the bookshelf near the photo of a wolf, until one week when Mr. Ablao went on vacation and the kids had a substitute. When Mr. Ablao came back, Bobsister was gone, vanished, disappeared, and was all the kids wanted to talk about. This is the point where everybody in class gets very, very interested in Bobsister.
所以，性别不明的“鲍勃妹妹”就一直住在狼照片旁边的书架上，直到有一周阿布劳老师去度假，班里来了一位代课老师。当阿布劳老师回来时，鲍勃妹妹不见了——消失了，不见踪影，而这成了孩子们唯一想谈论的话题。这时，班里所有人都对鲍勃妹妹产生了极其浓厚的兴趣。
There's kind of all this speculation about what happened to Bobsister. Was she stolen? Was she murdered? Did she die? And so, I go and I look a little bit. I looked under the desk. I looked behind the bookshelf and--
大家对鲍勃妹妹的遭遇进行了各种猜测。她是被偷了吗？她被谋杀了吗？她死了吗？所以我去仔细查了一下。我看了桌子底下。我看了书架后面，然后——
Did you ask the substitute?
你问代课老师了吗？
I did, actually. He had no idea what I was talking about, which was good enough for me.
问了。他完全不知道我在说什么，这对我来说就够了。
Oh, really? For me, that makes him suspect number one.
哦，真的吗？对我来说，这让他成了头号嫌疑人。
[LAUGHS] Interesting.
[笑] 有意思。
There's your guy. Do you not watch any crime drama at all?
嫌疑人就在那儿。你难道一点犯罪剧都不看吗？
There are all kinds of theories about what happened to Bobsister. Antonio and Dylan said it was really fun to talk about-- various abductors, including animals from an alternate universe. But Dylan says the prime suspect for his classmates? That other picture on the bookshelf.
关于鲍勃妹妹发生了什么，有各种各样的理论。安东尼奥和迪伦说讨论这个真的很有趣——各种绑架者，包括来自平行宇宙的动物。但迪伦说，同学们眼中的头号嫌疑人是谁吗？书架上的另一幅画。
They just decided that the wolf ate it because it was right above the wolf.
他们认定是狼把它吃了，因为它就在狼的上方。
Like the wolf was jealous or something.
好像是狼嫉妒什么的。
They didn't really know why. They just-- that's what they said.
他们并不真正知道为什么。他们只是——他们就是这么说的。
Who said that?
谁说的？
Basically everybody.
基本上所有人。
I mean, he's a wolf.
我是说，它毕竟是匹狼。
Yeah.
没错。
The chatter about Bobsister does not go away, which is funny, but also Mr. Ablao's got a curriculum to get through.
关于鲍勃妹妹的议论一直没停，这很有趣，但阿布劳老师还有课程要赶。
And I'm kind of vaguely annoyed because there's a lot going on in the school day, and I don't have much time to think about a picture of Bobsister. But they're kind of pestering me about it. And then one other student--
我有点莫名的烦躁，因为一天的学校生活有很多事，我没太多时间去想那幅鲍勃妹妹的画。但他们一直在纠缠我。然后另一个学生——
Dylan, actually.
其实是迪伦。
--pipes in and says, can we have a funeral for Bobsister? And I'm like, what are you talking about? And they're like, well, she died. Something happened. And I'm like, a funeral for Bobsister, a picture? And I say yes.
——插话说，我们可以为鲍勃妹妹办一场葬礼吗？我问你们在说什么？他们说，她死了。发生了一些事。我说，给鲍勃妹妹办葬礼，就因为一张画？我说行吧。
Probably just to get them to stop talking about Bobsister. But also, this is the kind of teacher he is. He says, sometimes, it's smart to take some detours, follow things the way they lead.
可能只是想让他们停止讨论鲍勃妹妹。但也因为这就是他那种风格的老师。他说，有时候，采取迂回策略，顺着事态发展去应对是明智的。
And they're like, when? I'm like, uh, I don't know when. I don't know when this funeral is going to happen. And they're like, when? When's it going to happen? When's it going to happen? We are going to have a funeral for Bobsister. And so then, finally, I'm like, after the recess on Friday.
他们问，什么时候？我说，呃，我不知道什么时候。我不知道这场葬礼什么时候举行。他们一直问，什么时候？什么时候举行？我们要给鲍勃妹妹办葬礼。最后我说，周五课间休息后吧。
That was Monday. The rest of the week goes pretty normally. Mr. Ablao sort of hoped that they would forget about the funeral by the end of the week, but no way. They were murmuring about it, preparing for it-- which he has no part of. The eight-year-olds are the ones organizing this and thinking it through. Finally, Friday arrives, the big day, the day of the funeral. The kids come back into the room from recess.
那天是周一。接下来的一周过得很平常。阿布劳老师原本希望他们到周末会忘了葬礼的事，但根本没可能。他们一直在窃窃私语，为葬礼做准备——他完全没参与。这些八岁的孩子正在组织这一切，并认真思考着。终于，周五到了，大日子，葬礼之日。孩子们课间休息后回到教室。
They're pretty giddy and pretty excited, so finally, I'm like, OK, game on, let's go. Funeral. I have no idea what is about to transpire. All of a sudden, boom, the tables kind of move out of the way. The leader of the funeral comes up with the stool. Two other students bring two tables and grab the flowers. Apparently, a bunch of girls had been making posters. They write Bobsister's Funeral on the board.
他们非常激动兴奋，所以我终于说，好吧，开始吧，葬礼。我根本不知道接下来会发生什么。突然，砰的一声，桌子被移开了。葬礼的组织者带着凳子走上来。另外两个学生拿来两张桌子，还拿了花。显然，一群女孩一直在做海报。她们在黑板上写下“鲍勃妹妹的葬礼”。
Dylan's the leader of the funeral. And he prepared a eulogy. So did his friend, Theo. Dylan gets in front of the class, holding a microphone Mr. Ablao keeps in the room.
迪伦是葬礼的负责人。他还准备了一篇悼词。他的朋友西奥也准备了。迪伦拿着阿布劳老师放在教室里的麦克风站在班级前面。
The rest of the class is totally on the edge of their seats, just waiting for this kid to start the funeral, like paying more attention to him than they ever paid to me. And they were just ready for it. He starts out kind of ad-libbing about welcoming everyone, thanking everyone for coming to celebrate the life of Bobsister.
班里剩下的孩子都坐在座位边缘，全神贯注地等着这个孩子开始葬礼，他们投入的关注度比平时上课时高多了。他们已经准备好了。他开始即兴发挥，欢迎大家，感谢大家的到来，共同纪念鲍勃妹妹的一生。
Now, how did you know what to say in the eulogy?
你是怎么知道悼词该说些什么的？
We didn't. We just said some things that sounded about right, like something that you might say at a funeral that might make someone cry.
不知道。我们只是说了些听起来很合适的话，就像你在葬礼上可能会说的，可能会让别人哭的话。
Do you have your eulogy there?
你有那份悼词吗？
Yeah. Take it out?
有。拿出来吗？
Could you read it?
你能读一下吗？
OK, one sec. And then it sort of-- mine also says, sort of back and forth, she and he, so. Because I didn't really know. "Bobsister was a great person. People thought that Bob was just a drawing on a piece of paper, but I knew he was anything but that. But she is still in here. She made me think I could do things in school. If she was here today, she would say keep on trying."
好吧，等一下。这上面有点……我的悼词里也是，一会儿说她，一会儿说他，所以……因为我真的不知道。 “鲍勃妹妹是个伟大的人。人们认为鲍勃只是纸上的一幅画，但我知道他绝不仅仅是那样。但她依然在这里。她让我觉得自己在学校里能做到很多事。如果她今天在这儿，她会说继续努力。”
That's really nice. It sounds like you were trying to be sort of inspiring.
太棒了。听起来你想表现得很励志。
Yeah.
是啊。
Had you seen a eulogy in a movie or something that you knew what to do?
你是在电影里见过葬礼所以知道该怎么做吗？
Nope, never.
没有，从来没见过。
Whoa.
哇。
The other eulogy that Theo wrote was also really good. "I just want to say something about the special person here, Bobsister. She was such a good friend to all the potatoes and especially, Mr. Potato Head." Potatoes were another fascination in Mr. Ablao's class that year. "What an honor it was to have her with us. God bless her." And then, from the back of the room, Mr. Ablao hears a boy crying.
西奥写的另一篇悼词也非常好。“我只想说点关于这位特殊的人，鲍勃妹妹的事。她对所有的土豆来说都是个好朋友，尤其是土豆先生。”土豆是那一年阿布劳班里另一个让孩子们着迷的东西。“能有她陪伴是我们的荣幸。上帝保佑她。”然后，从教室后面，阿布劳老师听到一个男孩在哭。
I would say almost wailing, but it was like a real cry. And at first, I'm thinking, oh my God, now they're just turning this into a joke. And then, I realized that he's actually seriously crying. Like, this is not a joke cry.
我想说是嚎啕大哭，但这是一种真实的哭泣。起初我心想，天哪，他们这是在拿这事开玩笑。然后我意识到他真的是在认真地哭。这不是那种恶作剧的哭。
And I walk back there. And everyone kind of turns back. Everyone's looking at both of us. And so, I ask him. I was like, what's wrong? What's going on? Why are you crying? And he's like, it's because Bobsister died. And I was like, it's not about anything else? Maybe? And he's like, no, it's Bobsister has died, and it's just so sad.
我走过去。大家都转过头来。所有人都看着我们俩。所以我问他，怎么了？发生什么事了？你为什么哭？他说，因为鲍勃妹妹死了。我说，不是因为别的什么事？或许？他说，不是，就是鲍勃妹妹死了，太悲伤了。
Mr. Ablao thinks maybe it was really about his dog. The dog that boy had grown up with had died just two weeks before. His mom had sent an email to let him know. But Mr. Ablao is really not sure. At eight, you're old enough to catch a glimpse of what death means.
阿布劳老师心想，他可能真的是在为他的狗哭。那个男孩从小一起长大的狗两周前刚去世。他妈妈发了封邮件告诉他。但阿布劳老师也不确定。八岁，正是开始模糊理解死亡意味着什么的年纪。
And then I look up, and then the whole kind of feel of the classroom has changed. It's gone from kind of giddy excitement, this is a fun thing, to half the class is nervously laughing. And the other half looks like they're on the verge of tears. There's about three girls that are kind of really sad. And I was like, oh no, what have I created?
然后我抬头看，教室的气氛完全变了。从那种轻快的兴奋，觉得这是一个有趣的事，变成了班里一半的人在紧张地笑着。另一半看起来快要哭了。大约有三个女孩真的非常难过。我心想，天哪，我到底创造了什么？
This was reaching an emotional level that I actually had never experienced before. And I've been teaching for about 15 years. And I had never felt kind of this-- not that it was getting out of control, but it was it was leading to something that I didn't know how it was going to end, honestly. I don't know what's going to happen next. If three other kids start crying, I don't know how to handle the situation.
这触及了我之前从未经历过的情感深度。我教书大约15年了。我从没感受到过这种——不是说场面失控了，而是它正走向某种我确实不知道该如何收场的结果。我不知道接下来会发生什么。如果另外三个孩子开始哭，我不知道该怎么处理这种情况。
Right.
没错。
I had never experienced that in a classroom.
我从来没在教室里经历过这种情况。
It's so interesting. It's like they were playing around with-- I don't know-- a Ouija board and joking around. And suddenly, they accidentally summoned a demon into the room.
这真有意思。就像他们玩——不知道——通灵板在开玩笑。突然间，他们不小心把一个恶魔召唤到了房间里。
Yeah, in a way. And for me, I was right there on the Ouija board with them.
是的，从某种意义上说。对我而言，我就和他们一起在那块通灵板上。
And so this monster's in the room. You've unleashed this, really, kind of a primal force, this grief, right?
所以这个怪物就在房间里。你释放了这种，真的，一种原始的力量，这种悲伤，对吧？
Yeah, grief, death. Mm-hmm. And I mean, one of the really neat things about third grade is, it's-- I mean, there's a saying, they stop learning to read and are reading to learn. So it's an age where their world gets a lot bigger. They kind of are experiencing real things. And I think a funeral is one of those things. They probably all heard of a funeral. They read them in books, but most of them probably hadn't been to one and didn't know what that felt like.
对，悲伤，死亡。嗯。我的意思是，三年级学生非常特别的一点是，有句老话，他们不再为了学习而阅读，而是为了阅读而学习。所以这是一个他们的世界变得更广阔的年纪。他们正在体验真实的东西。我想葬礼就是其中之一。他们可能都听说过葬礼，在书里读到过，但他们中的大多数可能没参加过，不知道那种感觉是什么样的。
And Mr. Ablao felt responsible to help them through this new experience, like he had lots of others that year. So he took control of the room back from the kids and addressed them all.
阿布劳老师觉得有责任帮助他们度过这种新体验，就像他那一年帮助他们度过其他很多事情一样。所以他从孩子们手中夺回了课堂的主导权，对大家说。
I was like, well, funerals are kind of serious. Sometimes when you go to a funeral, it's very sad because you're missing the person that's moved on. And sometimes it reminds you of other people who have moved on. And it's important to remember those people. And it's important to be sad. And this is the end of the funeral.
我说，嗯，葬礼是有点严肃的事。有时候你去参加葬礼，会非常悲伤，因为你在思念那个已经离开的人。有时候它会让你想起其他已经离开的人。记住那些人很重要。悲伤也是很重要的一部分。葬礼到此结束。
Which worked. Everybody snapped out of it. The demon left the room. Next was free time, which they all enjoy, and everything was fine. But at the end of the school year, when the class stood in a circle and each kid named something that they remembered and liked from third grade, a couple of the kids said Bobsister's funeral. It was a moment for Mr. Ablao, too.
这一招管用了。大家立刻从情绪中走出来了。恶魔离开了房间。接下来是自由活动时间，他们都很喜欢，一切都恢复了正常。但在学年末，当班里的学生围成一圈，每个孩子说出一件他们从三年级学到的记得并喜欢的事时，有几个孩子说了“鲍勃妹妹的葬礼”。这也是阿布劳老师的一个瞬间。
Sometimes you're joking around, and it's all light and fun and trying something you've never done before. And some bigger subterranean force gets unleashed. That's what our show is going to be about today, those moments when you get a glimpse of all that feeling that's there down below, hidden from sight. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
有时候你只是在开玩笑，一切都轻松有趣，试图做一些你从未做过的事情。然后一些更大的潜意识力量被释放了出来。这就是我们今天要讲的内容，那些当你瞥见深埋在表面之下，隐藏在视线之外的所有情感的时刻。这里是 WBEZ 芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Through the Eye of a Needle. So let's move now from young people contemplating death to the exact opposite-- older people realizing that their lives are saved and feeling great about it. And one place where people are feeling that feeling lately-- when they get the coronavirus vaccine. All over our great nation, over a million people a day are now getting the vaccine, which still leaves most of us-- speaking for myself-- jealous and wondering what happens in those little rooms.
第一幕，针孔看世界。那么现在让我们从思考死亡的年轻人转向完全相反的境地——意识到自己的生命获救并为此感到无比美妙的老年人。最近人们感受到这种感觉的一个地方——当他们接种新冠疫苗时。在我们伟大的国家，每天有超过一百万人正在接种疫苗，这依然让我们大多数人——就我个人而言——感到嫉妒，并好奇在那些小房间里到底发生了什么。
Nurses are coming out of retirement, sometimes without pay, to volunteer and give us shots and try to save us all. Tobin Low, one of our editors here, his mom is one of those nurses-- has been doing vaccinations in California.
护士们正从退休中回归，有时甚至是无偿的，志愿为我们注射疫苗，试图拯救我们所有人。我们节目的编辑之一托宾·洛，他的妈妈就是其中一位护士——一直在加州进行疫苗接种工作。
I want to ask you about the first person that you gave the vaccine to. Can you tell me that story?
我想问你关于你给注射疫苗的第一人。你能讲讲那个故事吗？
Remind me a little bit, because I've been doing this now for--
提醒我一下，因为我已经做了这么久了——
Mom, it was dad.
妈，是爸爸。
Oh, oh!
哦，噢！
You gave dad--
你给爸爸注射了——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You're right. So, um.
你说得对。所以，嗯。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Boy.
天呐。
So tell me about vaccinating dad.
说说给爸爸接种的事吧。
OK. I had not given a vaccine in 15 years. And so, he was my first vaccine after 15 years. He was a good sport about it. And it all went well.
好的。我已经15年没打过疫苗了。所以，他是15年来我的第一个接种对象。他表现得很配合。一切都很顺利。
Was there a kiss afterwards, or is that unprofessional?
之后有吻别吗，还是那太不专业了？
You know, we were in a work setting. And so, it was all business.
你知道，我们在工作场所。所以，完全是公事公办。
It's not always all business. Feelings do bubble up to the surface. One of our producers, David Kestenbaum, was curious about what happens when people get the shots. He talked to nurses who have been administering the vaccine, sometimes going through this kind of intense moment with total strangers, one after another. Here's David.
并不总是公事公办的。情感确实会涌上心头。我们的一位制片人戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆对人们接种疫苗时会发生什么感到好奇。他采访了那些一直负责注射疫苗的护士，有时他们会与完全陌生的人接连经历这种强烈的瞬间。这是戴维带来的报道。
Iris Sanchez heard they were looking for nurses to volunteer in Texas in an email. I don't think she even finished reading it.
艾丽斯·桑切斯在一封电子邮件中听说他们正在寻找护士去德州当志愿者。我想她甚至没读完那封信。
Oh my God, I got so excited because I know that these spots fill up really fast. So I just kept looking, and my hands were shaking. Like, where's the link? Where's the link? I want to beat everybody to it. I don't want to get left out, so.
天哪，我太兴奋了，因为我知道这些名额填满得非常快。所以我一直在找，我的手在发抖。就像，链接在哪？链接在哪？我想抢在所有人前面。我不想被落下。
That's how people describe signing up to get the vaccine.
人们就是这样描述预约接种疫苗的。
You know what? Yeah, you're right. The spots fill up pretty fast, so there's this rush of, I want to be the first one to sign up for it.
你知道吗？是的，你说得对。名额很快就会满，所以有一种冲动，我想成为第一个预约到的人。
Iris sits at vaccination station number 2, or number 10. It varies, wherever they put her that day. She's in the Alamodome in San Antonio, this huge stadium where the Spurs used to play. I imagine them down on the court, but she's like, no, no, we're up in the hallway, where you get your beer and nachos. That's where they're giving the vaccines. Though somehow the word "vaccine" seems inadequate.
艾丽斯坐在2号接种站，或者10号。位置不定，看那天他们把她安排在哪。她就在圣安东尼奥的阿拉莫穹顶，那个巨大的体育馆，马刺队曾经在那里比赛。我本以为他们在球场下，但她说，不，不，我们在走廊上，就是你买啤酒和玉米片的那个地方。他们就是在那里接种疫苗。尽管不知何故，“疫苗”这个词似乎显得不足以概括。
I call it "the precious."
我叫它“宝贝”。
You call it the precious?
你叫它宝贝？
I call it the precious. So let me tell you about the precious, if everybody wants to know about the precious. I call it the precious because it's just so precious. So you have people in the drawing room in what we call the pharmacy. And there's this black curtain, and it says Pharmacy. And you can't go in there. It's like the Wizard of Oz.
我叫它宝贝。所以让我告诉你关于宝贝的事，如果每个人都想知道的话。我叫它宝贝，因为它太珍贵了。药房里有个画图室，我们这么称呼它。那里有道黑色窗帘，上面写着“药房”。你不能进去。就像《绿野仙踪》一样。
And they have people actually drawing up the vaccines. And they put them on a little tray, and then they're covered with this drape. And then they lift up the little drape, and you have all these little precious vaccines on there. And you get to pick one, and then you have to put it underneath the drape on your table.
他们确实有人在准备疫苗。他们把疫苗放在一个小托盘上，然后用帘子盖住。然后他们掀开帘子，你就能看到上面所有这些小小的珍贵疫苗。你可以选一个，然后你必须把它放在你桌上的帘子下面。
And so people would say, why are you hiding the vaccine? Why don't you want me to see it? And it's like, no, it's just it's very light sensitive, so we have to keep it covered so it can be asleep until it's ready, and then I'll give you your vaccine. I said, but look, it's here. It's right there. You are getting a vaccine today.
人们会问，你为什么要藏着疫苗？你为什么不让我看？我说，不，它只是对光非常敏感，所以我们必须盖住它，让它保持“睡眠”状态，直到准备好，然后我就给你注射疫苗。我说，但你看，它在这儿。它就在这儿。你今天就能接种疫苗了。
Pfizer, for the record, says that once the vial has been thawed, it is OK to expose the vaccine to room light. People are nervous about getting vaccinated, not because they don't want to be protected against the deadly disease. It's so much simpler. They don't like needles. Iris has a whole strategy for dealing with that.
顺便说一下，辉瑞公司表示，一旦药瓶解冻，将疫苗暴露在室内光线下是可以的。人们对接种疫苗感到紧张，不是因为他们不想保护自己免受致命疾病的侵害。原因更简单。他们不喜欢针头。艾丽斯有一整套应对策略。
You just tell them, don't look. Just don't look. And I talk to them. I'm like a little chatterbox. I'm like, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And I'm like, OK, we're done. And they're like, oh! Because I'm distracting them, so they're like, this woman won't shut up. But there is a reason for my madness. You just talk, and you're distracting them because they're like, she's going to shut up when she's ready to give me the shot, so they're not expecting it. And then bam, there you go. It's done.
你只要告诉他们，别看。就是别看。然后我和他们说话。我就像个小话痨。我说，巴拉巴拉巴拉……我说，好了，结束了。他们说，噢！因为我分散了他们的注意力，所以他们觉得，这个女人在给我打针之前是不会闭嘴的，所以他们毫无防备。然后砰，好了，结束了。
Iris volunteered to do this. She's not getting paid. Her full-time job is in endocrinology, so a lot of patients with diabetes. It's been a rough year. One of her favorite patients died from COVID. In this moment, when people get the shot, it can be intense. She only spends a few minutes with each person, but people tell you stuff.
艾丽斯是自愿做这件事的。她没有酬劳。她的全职工作是内分泌科，所以有很多糖尿病患者。这真是艰难的一年。她最喜欢的病人之一死于新冠。在人们打针的那一刻，气氛可能很强烈。她和每个人只待几分钟，但人们会告诉你一些事。
I had this young man. He was in his 40s, and he came in for the vaccine. And this was on a Tuesday. And he said, my parents are really happy that I'm here because my brother just died on Friday from COVID. He didn't make it. So my parents were just so sad, and they're just happy that I'm here because they don't want to lose their second child. Because if I die, then they don't have any more children. That was sad. That was really sad.
我有过一个年轻人。他40多岁，来打疫苗。那天是周二。他说，我父母真的很高兴我在这儿，因为我哥哥周五刚因新冠去世了。他没挺过来。所以我父母非常悲伤，他们只是很高兴我在这儿，因为他们不想失去第二个孩子。因为如果我也死了，他们就没孩子了。那真悲伤。真的很悲伤。
Oh my god.
天呐。
In the 40s, gosh, yeah.
40多岁，天呐，是啊。
The man told Iris it was his parents who had actually gone online to sign up, but they could only get one appointment. And they decided he should have it. They thought it was more important that he get the shot. He qualified because he had an underlying medical condition. The guy showed a picture of him and his brother. He'd made it the home screen on his phone.
那个人告诉艾丽斯，其实是他父母上网帮他预约的，但他们只能预约到一个名额。他们决定让他去打。他们认为他打上疫苗更重要。他符合资格是因为他有基础疾病。那个人展示了一张他和哥哥的照片。他把它设成了手机的主屏壁纸。
Tobin's mom, who you heard earlier, Vivian Low, told this story about a different family.
托宾的妈妈，也就是你刚才听到的薇薇安·洛，讲了关于另一个家庭的故事。
So I had this woman who came in who brought her mom in. And I looked at her health questionnaire and she had answered no to everything, that she never had an allergic reaction. She wasn't on any immunosuppressants. All the answers were no, and so I said, great, let's give you your shot. And so, I actually delivered the vaccine. And as I was already injecting it into her mom's arm, her mom said, well, I'm glad that's over, because man, I had a really bad reaction to that flu vaccine.
有个女人带着她妈妈来了。我看了她的健康问卷，她所有项都填了“否”，说她从未有过过敏反应。她没在使用任何免疫抑制剂。所有答案都是否，所以我说，太好了，我们打针吧。于是我真的给她的妈妈注射了疫苗。就在我已经把针扎进她妈妈手臂时，她妈妈说，好了，我真高兴这一切结束了，因为天呐，上次打流感疫苗我产生了严重的反应。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
And I said, you had an allergic, an anaphylactic reaction? I said, were you hospitalized? Oh, yeah. And then the daughter just jumped right in and said, mom, it's fine. You were fine. This is irrelevant information. You needed this vaccine. You got this vaccine. The daughter was so intent on protecting her mom.
我说，你产生了过敏性休克吗？我说，你住院了吗？噢，是的。然后女儿立刻插话说，妈，没事。你没事。这是无关信息。你需要这个疫苗。你已经打上这个疫苗了。女儿一心只想保护她的妈妈。
Iris has had uncomfortable situations, too. Like, this one guy had gone online, managed to get an appointment, but he wasn't diabetic. He didn't have a heart condition. He wasn't over 65. If there's any reason she can find to legitimately give someone a shot, she wants to. And sometimes she gets people in by asking their height and weight to see if their BMI is 30 or over. His was 29.5. She rounded up.
艾丽斯也遇到过尴尬的情况。比如，有个家伙上网预约到了，但他不患糖尿病。他没心脏病。他不到65岁。只要她能找到任何理由合法给某人打上一针，她都愿意。有时她会问他们的身高体重来看看BMI是否达到30或以上。他是29.5。她给他四舍五入上去了。
So in his case, he was obese. He was an overweight. He was obese, so that's why I qualified him for the vaccine. And I like to say, I'm not trying to offend you, but you qualify. And they're like, it's OK. For once, I'm happy to be overweight because that means I can get the vaccine.
所以对他来说，他属于肥胖。他是超重。他属于肥胖，所以我让他有了接种资格。我喜欢说，我不是想冒犯你，但你符合资格。他们说，没关系。我有史以来第一次因为超重而感到高兴，因为这意味着我可以接种疫苗。
There can be an intimacy to this moment of getting the shot, I think because there's a way in which getting the shot is like passing through a portal-- out of this awful year. This other nurse, Amy Caramore in New York, told me she feels that way with every single shot.
我想，在打针的那一刻有一种亲密感，因为打针就像穿过一扇传送门——走出这糟糕的一年。纽约的另一位护士艾米·卡拉莫告诉我，她在每一次注射时都有这种感觉。
I say, are you ready? I always say, are you ready, which is a little bit-- which isn't just about, are you ready for me to put a needle in your arm, but is more about, are you ready for this?
我说，你准备好了吗？我总是问，你准备好了吗，这不仅仅是关于——你准备好让我把针扎进你手臂了吗，而是更多关于，你准备好迎接这个了吗？
It's like, are you ready for the new world?
就像是，你准备好迎接新世界了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Is that what you mean?
你是这个意思吗？
Yeah, are you ready for something different? And here we go.
是的，你准备好迎接某种不同的东西了吗？现在我们开始吧。
We actually have a recording of someone getting a shot that kind of captures this. We put a mic on Tobin's mom out in California. This man, James, gets sent to her. He'd gotten there way before his appointment. They go over the paperwork. Date of birth-- he's 82. Old, he says.
我们其实录下了某人接种疫苗的过程，捕捉到了这一点。我们在加州给托宾的妈妈装了麦克风。这个叫詹姆斯的男人被送到了她那儿。他在预约时间前早就到了。他们检查了文书。出生日期——他82岁了。老了，他说。
All right, just relax this arm. There you go. You're great. You've gotten flu shots before?
好的，放松这条手臂。这就对了。你表现得很好。你以前打过流感疫苗吗？
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
Yeah, so this is just like that.
是的，所以这和那个一样。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
That's it. You glad it's over?
好了。你高兴结束了吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Woo-hoo!
呜呼！
Oh, boy.
天呐。
I had a young woman, and as I was going over the instructions, as I was going over the consent, she just burst into tears.
我有个年轻女病人，当我在过流程时，当我过知情同意书时，她突然泪流满面。
Again, Amy in New York.
还是纽约的艾米。
And I put my hand on her shoulder, and I said, are you OK? And she just said, I just am having a lot of feelings. I've just been so worried. It's like the tension has been so taut. It's been so tight, and everybody's been surviving with that. And then, we sit down in this moment together. And it's like, snap. But it's a big force. It's like, if you let go before, then everything was going to fall apart. The whole world was going to fall apart. And if you let go right now in this room, maybe not.
我把手放在她肩上，说，你还好吗？她说，我只是感慨万千。我一直太担心了。那种紧张感一直紧绷着。一直太紧了，每个人都靠着那股劲儿活了下来。然后，我们在这一刻坐在一起。就像是，断了。但这是一种巨大的力量。就像是，如果你在那之前放手，那一切都会崩溃。整个世界都会崩溃。而如果你现在在房间里放手，或许就不会。
All the vaccinations end the same way, she says. After people get their shot, they have to go to an observation area, just to make sure they don't have an allergic reaction.
她说，所有的疫苗接种都以同样的方式结束。人们打完针后，必须去观察区，以确保他们没过敏反应。
It's funny because you're walking in-- I walk my person, right? Because I'm not going to just send them down the hall and say, good luck now. We just did this big thing. So I walk my person to there, and they go-- usually a big smiley person at this point, right? Because they're like, they survived the moment, you know? And they go walk into a room, and then the room is just a bunch of people sitting six feet apart, texting on their phones.
很有趣，因为你走进去——我陪着我接种的人走进去，对吧？因为我不能只把他们打发到走廊里说，祝你好运。我们刚刚完成了这么大的事。所以我陪着我的病人走过去，他们表现得——通常这时候都是笑嘻嘻的，对吧？因为他们觉得，他们挺过了那一刻，你知道吗？他们走进房间，房间里只是一群人相隔六英尺坐着，低头看手机。
Welcome to the afterlife.
欢迎来到死后的世界。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yeah, it's exactly as you remember it-- a bunch of people sitting.
是的，和你记忆中一模一样——一群人坐着。
On their phones.
看着手机。
On their phones texting.
在手机上发短信。
We really should change that, she says. Fill the room with balloons-- something.
她说，我们真应该改变一下。让房间里充满气球——做点什么。
David Kestenbaum is senior editor of our show.
戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的高级编辑。
Act Two, Penny for Your Non-Thoughts. We were talking here at the show about the theme of today's program-- what lies beneath the surface. One of our producers, Lilly Sullivan, mentioned something that a bunch of us know quite well-- that she wonders what happens beneath the surface in the mind of one of her friends who also works here at the radio show. Over the years, she has talked to a number of us on staff about this. She's read articles trying to better understand. And finally, just this past week, once and for all, she tried to get to the bottom of it. Here's Lilly.
第二幕，给你的非思绪投一便士。我们在节目组谈论今天节目的主题——表面之下潜藏着什么。我们的制片人莉莉·沙利文提到了一件我们很多人非常清楚的事情——她很好奇在她的一个也在这个广播节目工作的朋友大脑表面之下到底发生了什么。多年来，她和我们台里的不少人谈过这个话题。她读过很多试图更好地理解这一点的文章。最后，就在过去的一周里，她试图一劳永逸地弄个水落石出。这是莉莉。
Diane and I have worked together for four years. We started at the show at the same time. We were the junior staffers. And we became the kind of work friends where we had neighboring offices, so we'd overhear everything through the walls. We'd go into each other's offices, close the doors, pull down the blinds, and talk. We'd always sit on the ground because-- I don't know-- chairs felt weirdly formal.
黛安和我共事四年了。我们同时进入这个节目。我们是初级员工。我们成了那种工作朋友，办公室挨着，所以能隔墙听到一切。我们会走进对方的办公室，关上门，拉下百叶窗，聊天。我们总是坐在地上，因为——我不知道——椅子感觉太正式了。
And then one day, she told me this thing. She said, I don't introspect hardly ever, hardly at all-- meaning she spends almost no time looking inward. She doesn't really think about herself, her thoughts, her feelings about the world almost ever. This got so deep in my head. To not introspect-- I didn't even know that was possible, as if there's a menu somewhere of ways to be. An introspection is just an option that one could choose or not choose. I didn't even know there was a menu.
然后有一天，她告诉我一件事。她说，我几乎从不内省，几乎完全没有——意味着她几乎不花时间向内看。她几乎从不思考自己、自己的想法、自己对世界的感受。这深深地印在了我的脑海里。不内省——我甚至不知道这是可能的，就好像有个菜单列出了成为一个人的方式。而内省只是一个人可以选择或不选择的选项。我甚至不知道有菜单这回事。
And how could it be true? I would watch her, confounded. Diane says insightful things. She's considerate-- always considerate, by the way, exceedingly. And I'd think, how did she anticipate those needs? How did she have that insight? She doesn't look inside. I assumed we were misunderstanding each other, that she must introspect. She must reflect on all sorts of things. She just doesn't use the word "introspection" to describe it. We're probably doing the same thing. We just don't categorize it the same way. Diane says, no.
这怎么可能是真的？我看着她，感到困惑。黛安会说出很有见地的话。她很体贴——顺便说一句，总是很体贴，非常体贴。我会想，她是怎么预见到那些需求的？她怎么会有那种洞察力？她并不向内看。我以为我们误解了对方，她肯定会内省。她肯定会反思各种事情。她只是不用“内省”这个词来形容它。我们可能做的是同一件事。我们只是没把它们归类为同一种。黛安说，不。
Well, since you started asking me about this, I've been thinking about it, you know? And I knew we were going to talk about this. So walking into the grocery store the other night, I was walking in, and I was just like, what would I be thinking about if I were introspecting right now? And I had no idea.
好吧，自从你开始问我这个问题，我就一直在思考，你知道吗？我知道我们要谈这个。所以前几天晚上走进杂货店时，我走进去，我只是在想，如果我现在在内省，我会在想什么？我完全不知道。
I was like, what could you possibly think about besides, there's some red shopping baskets. I'm going to take a red shopping basket. Oh, this is a spinach mix. Is it just spinach, or is there kale? That's literally all that's going on in my head. I can't imagine what else you could be thinking about. But I was like, I feel like I know if you are an introspective person, you could be, like, lost in your thoughts. But I just can't be in the grocery store.
我在想，除了“那有一些红色的购物篮，我要拿一个红色的购物篮。噢，这是菠菜混合菜，只有菠菜，还是有羽衣甘蓝？”你还能想什么？那字面上就是我脑子里发生的一切。我无法想象你还能想些什么。但我当时觉得，如果是一个内省的人，你可能会陷入沉思。但我无法在杂货店里做到。
Here's what I think about at the grocery store. I think, there's a red shopping basket. Should I get a basket or a cart? I don't like the rickety ones. I can't imagine shopping for a big family. I wonder if I'll ever have a big family. That ship has probably sailed. It must be expensive. Why did my mom always ask the person bagging groceries to help her to her car? Whatever happened to Volvos? I bit that hole in the headrest of her Volvo when I was five. Or was I four? She was so sad. Why was I like that?
我在杂货店时是这么想的。我想，那儿有个红色购物篮。我是拿个篮子还是手推车？我不喜欢那些晃晃悠悠的。我无法想象为一个大家庭购物。不知道我是否会有个大家庭。那艘船可能已经开走了。那一定很贵。为什么我妈总是让装袋的人帮她送到车上？沃尔沃后来怎么了？我五岁时咬了她那辆沃尔沃头枕上的洞。还是四岁？她当时很难过。我为什么要那样？
Is that guy looking at me? Is he mad? What's he mad about? I wonder how much that cashier makes? Are people nice to her? It must take a long time to memorize all the codes to the produce so you don't need that sheet anymore. I'd be bad at it. Do people ask her if it's hard? Would she like that question or find it rude?
那家伙在看我吗？他生气吗？他为什么生气？不知道那个收银员挣多少钱？人们对她好吗？记忆所有农产品的代码不需要那张纸一定很费时间吧。我肯定不行。有人会问她这工作难吗？她是会喜欢那个问题，还是觉得粗鲁？
A lot of my thoughts are just imagining other people's thoughts and feelings, all tangled up with my own. It's probably like 95% of what I think about. Diane says she doesn't do that-- at all. And one of the reasons I believe her is that she remembers the moment that she first realized that her brain works this way. She told me that thinking about one's thoughts, or not thinking about them-- she was 24 before she realized it was a thing at all. She was reading a book of essays by a doctor.
我的很多想法只是在想象别人的想法和感受，跟我自己的搅在一起。那可能占了我思维的95%。黛安说她根本不做这些——一点也不。我相信她的原因之一是，她记得自己第一次意识到大脑是这样运作的那个时刻。她告诉我，关于思考一个人的想法，或者不思考它们——她直到24岁才意识到那是一回事。她当时正在读一本医生的文集。
There was a story about a girl or young woman who almost died of flesh-eating bacteria from walking on some grass. And I immediately started panicking that I was going to get a flesh-eating bacteria also, which is not how I usually operate at all ever. And I burst into tears and was really upset about it. [LAUGHS] And my ex was like, what's going on? Are you OK? And I was like, I just am worried that I'm going to die from flesh-eating bacteria. And also, my parents are going to die one day. It all just came rushing out.
有一个故事关于一个女孩或年轻女性，因为走过一些草地差点死于食肉菌。我立刻开始恐慌，觉得我也要得食肉菌了，这根本不是我平时的运作方式。我泪流满面，非常难过。[笑] 我前任问，发生什么了？你还好吗？我说，我只是担心我会死于食肉菌。而且，我父母有一天也会死。所有这一切都涌了出来。
And I was really upset about it, and he was like, oh, wow, you don't spend any time at all thinking about this usually, do you? And I was like, no, it's just something that reading this book made me realize that I'm going to die one day, and so are my parents. And I don't feel good about it. And he was like, oh, well, maybe if you were more introspective, like you took a couple of minutes every now and then, you wouldn't end up bursting in tears.
我当时非常难过，他说，噢，哇，你平时根本不花时间想这些，对吧？我说，不，只是读了这本书让我意识到有一天我会死，我父母也会。我感觉不好。他说，噢，好吧，如果你更内省一点，比如偶尔花几分钟反思一下，你就不会哭成这样了。
After that, Diane would occasionally try to force herself to sit down and introspect. It always felt hard, she says. Kind of fake and boring. And let's just dispel this categorically-- Diane is no dummy. She's incredibly focused. You can go to her with a big, complicated story, and she can hold the whole thing in her head, immediately get how everything's connected. She also happens to have a PhD in inorganic chemistry from Stanford. So she's not one to name drop.
在那之后，黛安偶尔会强迫自己坐下来内省。她说，这总是很难。感觉有点假，很无聊。让我们一劳永逸地消除这种误解——黛安绝非笨蛋。她极其专注。你可以带着一个宏大、复杂的复杂故事去找她，她能把整个故事记在脑子里，立刻抓住所有事物之间的联系。她碰巧在斯坦福大学获得了无机化学博士学位。所以她不是那种会随意卖弄的人。
I asked Diane if we could try to do a rapid response game. I wrote up some of my burning questions.
我问黛安我们是否可以玩一个快速反应游戏。我写下了一些我迫切想问的问题。
Just answer quickly, yes or no.
快点回答，是或否。
Oh, fun. OK, I'm ready. OK.
噢，好玩。好的，我准备好了。好的。
OK, here goes. If you see something, does it pull up other random associations and memories?
好的，开始了。如果你看到某样东西，它会引出其他随机的联想和记忆吗？
Sometimes. Rarely.
有时候。很少。
And then does that memory lead to other random memories that then start coursing through your head?
那么那个记忆会导致其他随机记忆开始在你脑海中流动吗？
No, just if I have one, it'll just be the one. It'll hang out there for a little bit.
不，如果我有记忆，那也就是那一个。它会在那儿挂一会儿。
OK. Do you spend a lot of time feeling just mildly guilty or mildly regretful about a thing you said a few minutes ago?
好的。你花很多时间对你几分钟前说的一句话感到有点内疚或有点后悔吗？
No, I don't.
不，我不。
Hmm. Do you think about your opinions and why you have those opinions and whether you actually should have those opinions?
嗯。你是否思考过你的观点，为什么你有这些观点，以及你是否真的应该持有这些观点？
Oh, wow. I feel like I don't really-- this is not going to sound good, but I don't think I have that many opinions. Or if I do, they're not strongly held.
噢，哇。我觉得我不怎么——这听起来不太好，但我认为我没那么多观点。或者如果有，它们也不是很强烈。
This did not help me get it. It confirmed for me that she doesn't think about all the things I think about. But I still didn't get what she thinks about instead. What is going through her head? And I understand how stonery this all sounds. We tried to describe to each other our experiences of consciousness. Sorry, everyone. First, me.
这没能帮我理解。它证实了我她确实不像我那样思考所有事情。但我还是没弄明白她用什么来代替。她脑子里在想什么？我明白这听起来像吸了大麻一样。我们试图向对方描述我们的意识体验。抱歉，各位。首先是我。
I think it feels more like a washing machine of thoughts jumbled up, and I'm jumping from one thing to another, but it's just all in there, mixed together, going and going all the time. Does that feel familiar?
我觉得它更像是一个乱七八糟的想法洗衣机，我从一件跳到另一件，但它们全都在里面，混在一起，一直在转。这听起来熟悉吗？
Not at all. I think it sounds like you. But I don't think it sounds like me.
一点也不。我觉得那听起来像你。但我不觉得它听起来像我。
OK, I feel like-- so can we, like-- could you try to think? And, like, if you had to describe what it's like-- because when I was thinking about this, I was like, oh, I wonder what appliance Diane would be. If you were to think for a second about--
好的，我觉得——那我们，能不能——你能试着思考吗？如果一定要描述那是什么样的感觉——因为当我思考这个时，我在想，噢，不知道黛安会是哪种电器。如果你花一秒钟思考——
Of what it feels like inside my head?
思考我脑袋里是什么感觉？
Yeah. Do you have any sense of--
对。你有什么感触吗——
I mean, the first thing that comes to mind is, I feel like a video camera that's just pointing to different things in the world. And it goes in. Most of it doesn't stay very long and goes right back out.
我的意思是，脑海里浮现的第一件事是，我觉得自己像是一台摄像机，只是指向世界上的不同事物。它进来了。大部分东西留存的时间不长，然后又出去了。
Wow, OK. And the thing that it's pointing at, is it pointing at thoughts in your head, or is it pointing at actual things in the world?
哇，好的。那个它指着的东西，它是指向你脑子里的想法，还是指向世界上实际的事物？
The actual things in the world-- very literally, like if my eyes were a camera.
世界上实际的事物——非常字面意思，就像如果我的眼睛是一台摄像机。
Yeah. So the video-- so do you just mean your eyes?
是的。所以录像——你是说你的眼睛？
It's like-- yeah, I think it's like, I spend 90% of my brain just taking in the inputs and--
就像是——是的，我觉得就像，我花了90%的大脑只是在接收输入，然后——
Wow.
哇。
It's really-- I mean, even in quiet moments, which I feel like I've had a ton of lately, I just end up staring out the window. And I'm not thinking about anything. I'm just observing the world around me.
真的很——我是说，即使是在安静的时刻，我觉得最近我有很多安静的时刻，我只是盯着窗外看。我什么都没想。我只是在观察周围的世界。
Huh. Is it nice? What does it feel like?
哈。感觉好吗？那是什么样的感觉？
I think before we started talking about all of this, I thought it was bad. I thought there was too much space in my head that was going to waste or something. But now that we've been talking about it, it is nice to have room. I feel like it lets me-- I feel generally sensitive to the world around me and to other people. And I think it's actually kind of nice that there is room to let the world in.
我觉得在我们开始谈论这一切之前，我认为那是坏事。我以为我的脑子里有太多空间被浪费了之类的。但现在我们谈论过之后，有空间感觉确实不错。我觉得这让我——我觉得自己对周围的世界和他人很敏感。而且我觉得空间能让世界进来其实挺好的。
It was like I had thought all humans were land creatures and that I kind of, more or less, understood our species. And then I found out that there are people who live in the ocean instead. And I know that I'll never live in the ocean. But now that Diane's explained it to me, put what's in her head into mine, I can imagine it. I spent the weekend just moving my eyes around my apartment, landing on different objects, just blinking.
就好像我一直以为所有人类都是陆地生物，我或多或少了解我们的物种。然后我发现有人住在海洋里。我知道我永远不会住在海洋里。但既然黛安向我解释了，把她脑子里的东西放进我的脑子里，我就能想象了。我周末只是在公寓里转动眼睛，落在不同的物体上，只是眨眼。
Lilly Sullivan and Diane Wu are both producers on our show. Coming up, what lurks beneath the surface of a sunny California afternoon if you had the kind of job that lets you see it. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
莉莉·沙利文和黛安·吴都是我们节目的制片人。接下来，如果你有一份能让你看到这些的工作，加州阳光明媚的下午表面之下潜藏着什么。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, What Lies Beneath. We have stories of stuff that is usually hidden from view coming to the surface. We have arrived at act three of our show. Act Three, One if By Land, Three if By Sea. So it's a conceit of a certain kind of story that, in one day, you can glimpse the entire world. This next story is kind of like that. Somebody catches a glimpse of something bigger in just three hours of a typical workday. Producer Dana Chivvis tells the story.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，表面之下。我们有那些通常隐藏在视线之外的东西浮出水面的故事。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，陆路一线，海路三线。某种故事的构思是，在一天之内，你可以瞥见整个世界。接下来的故事就是那样。某人在一个典型工作日的三小时内瞥见了更大的东西。制片人达纳·奇维斯讲述了这个故事。
A few weeks ago, I was calling around, talking to paramedics and EMTs in California. At the time, COVID cases had skyrocketed, and I wanted to see how the first responders were doing. I talked to this one guy, Sam Gebler. He's a firefighter and paramedic in San Francisco. And he told me the story. It actually happened back in August, all in one day, one of those perfect sunny days. Tons of people were outside that afternoon, enjoying the weather. And Sam was looking down at a woman who was caught on a cliff.
几周前，我到处打电话，和加州的护理人员和急救人员交谈。当时，新冠病例激增，我想看看一线人员的情况。我和一个叫萨姆·格布勒的家伙谈了。他是旧金山的消防员和护理人员。他告诉了我那个故事。它其实发生在八月份，就在一天之内，那是一个完美晴朗的日子。那天下午，成千上万的人在外面享受天气。而萨姆正俯视着一个被困在悬崖上的女人。
Where was the woman?
那个女人在哪？
She was probably 250 feet down the cliff. And it was kind of one of those things where she was standing-- it wasn't super steep. She could stand in balance, but there's no way to get down there. Honestly, to this day, I don't know how she made it down that far in that spot. It just didn't make any sense. And she had some scrapes and bruises on her, so I'm assuming she fell at some point and just happened, instead of rolling down the cliff into the water, she rolled on to this fairly flat spot with a rock to hold onto, which--
她可能在悬崖下250英尺处。那是一种她站着的情况——不算太陡。她能保持平衡站着，但根本没法下去。老实说，直到今天，我都不知道她是怎么在那儿走到那么下面的。这完全说不通。她身上有一些擦伤和瘀伤，所以我假设她在哪儿摔了一下，刚好滚到了这个相当平坦的地方，旁边有块岩石可以抓着，这——
Wow.
哇。
--was incredibly lucky because, with her in that state, there's no way she would have survived if she went into the water.
——非常幸运，因为以她当时的状态，如果她掉进水里，绝对活不下来。
How far down was the water from where she was?
她所在的地方离水面有多远？
Probably another 50 feet.
大概又往下50英尺。
The woman looked fairly young, late 20s, early 30s. And she was in a state like maybe she'd hit her head, or she was intoxicated. It wasn't clear. She wasn't answering questions. Sam's fire station covers an area of the city that includes beaches, Golden Gate Park, and these cliffs west of the Golden Gate Bridge, where people go hiking. So Sam and another firefighter put on face masks and harnesses, clipped into ropes, and lowered themselves down to her. When they got there, the woman was clearly in distress, but not because she was stuck on the side of the cliff.
那个女人看起来挺年轻的，20多岁末期或30多岁初期。她的状态就像是可能撞到了头，或者喝醉了。不清楚。她不回答问题。萨姆的消防站覆盖的区域包括海滩、金门公园和金门大桥西侧的悬崖，那是人们去徒步的地方。所以萨姆和另一名消防员戴上口罩和安全带，扣上绳索，把自己降下去。当他们到达时，女人显然处于痛苦中，但不是因为她被困在悬崖边。
I remember her saying a lot about how COVID has taken everything from her, and this disease is messing with her mind. And she doesn't know what to do and just being so overwhelmed at whatever-- I didn't ever get specifics of what she was doing before COVID or what her life was like, but she just kept saying, this disease is messing with me. I don't know what I'm doing. I don't have any reason to live, just all this crazy stuff. And in your mind, you're like, man. I mean, this is crazy, what it's doing to people.
我记得她说了很多关于新冠如何夺走了她的一切，这种疾病正在折磨她的心智。她不知道该怎么办，感到非常绝望，无论——我从没得到她新冠前在做什么或生活是什么样的具体信息，但她一直说，这种疾病在折磨我。我不知道我在做什么。我没什么活下去的理由，所有这些疯狂的事情。在你脑子里，你会想，天呐。我的意思是，这太疯狂了，它对人们造成的影响。
They put her in a harness and clipped her into the ropes. The rescuers up above started hauling the three of them back up the incline. But the woman was grabbing onto the rope, which is the intuitive thing to do when you're hanging off the side of a cliff, but it's actually really dangerous. The thing you're supposed to do is lean back, trust your harness and the ropes to hold you, and let your rescuers haul you back up. She wasn't doing that, and she wasn't in the right state of mind.
他们给她戴上安全带，把她扣在绳索上。上面的救援人员开始把他们三个顺着斜坡拉上来。但那个女人在抓绳子，当你挂在悬崖边时，那是直觉反应，但这其实非常危险。你应该做的是后仰，相信你的安全带和绳子能支撑你，让救援人员把你拉上来。她没这么做，她当时的精神状态也不对。
And so you're fighting this person to not climb up the rope, but to also walk their legs up the cliff.
所以你在和这个人较劲，不仅是为了不让她顺着绳子爬，还要让她的腿顺着悬崖走。
Right.
没错。
It's incredibly difficult with someone who isn't really able to follow commands. I mean, you're basically like a therapist at the edge of a cliff on a 250-foot cliff, trying to treat this person enough to get her up the cliff without getting yourself hurt. I mean, it's really--
对于一个无法听从指令的人来说，这极其困难。我的意思是，你本质上就像是一个250英尺高悬崖边的治疗师，试图在不让自己受伤的情况下治疗这个人并将她拉上来。我的意思是，这真的——
Oh my god.
天呐。
Yeah, it's kind of crazy. There were multiple times when I was getting frustrated. And I just needed to stop and calm myself down and look back and like, oh, wow, that looks really cool. And then, OK, all right. All right, stop talking about that. We're going to do one foot in front of the other now. [LAUGHS]
是的，这有点疯狂。我好几次感到沮丧。我只需要停下来让自己冷静下来，回头看，就像，噢，哇，那看起来真酷。然后，好吧，好了。好了，别再谈论那个了。我们现在一步一个脚印地走。[笑]
One foot in front of the other. Trust your rescuers, or you might fall backwards off a cliff. It feels applicable to all of us right now, trying to make it through this pandemic. It worked for Sam and this woman. With a lot of effort, they made it back up the slope. They put the woman into an ambulance and started driving back to the firehouse.
一步一个脚印。相信你的救援人员，否则你可能会向后坠崖。这感觉适用于我们现在所有试图度过这场疫情的人。这对萨姆和那个女人有效。经过巨大的努力，他们回到了斜坡上。他们把女人送上救护车，开始往消防站开车。
And that's when we hear on the radio, stand by for the surf rescue.
就在那时，我们听到无线电里说，待命进行冲浪救援。
Someone had spotted three kids in the water at a beach nearby. They seemed like they were in trouble. The currents at that beach are really strong. They can be deceptive.
有人发现附近海滩的水里有三个孩子。他们看起来有危险。那个海滩的海流非常强。它们可能很具欺骗性。
So he puts a U-turn on the street, and we start going back to the beach. So I'm peeling off my harness and dirty clothes and trying to get into my wetsuit. And I don't know if you've ever gotten into a wetsuit, but it's kind of difficult, especially when you're sweaty. It's sticky, and you're in the back of a fire engine that's driving code three to the beach. It's quite the spectacle. So we show up, and it's just a sea of people. I've never seen this many people at the beach before.
所以他在街上掉头，我们开始往海滩走。我正在脱掉安全带和脏衣服，试图穿上潜水服。我不知道你有没有穿过潜水服，这有点难，尤其是当你出汗的时候。它是粘的，而且你坐在正紧急驶向海滩的消防车后面。这真是个奇观。所以我们到了，那儿全是人。我以前从没见过海滩上有这么多人。
It's a nice day during a pandemic. There's nothing else to do but go outside. Sam told me when paramedics see crowds like that, they know they're going to have a busy day. The road is high above the beach, and from there, Sam can see three little dots in the water. He makes a mental note of where they are.
这是疫情期间美好的一天。除了去户外没别的事可做。萨姆告诉我，当护理人员看到那样的人群时，他们就知道这天会很忙。道路在海滩上方很高的地方，从那儿，萨姆能看到水里有三个小点。他记住了他们的位置。
Then he and about seven or eight other firefighters hop into the back of a special pickup truck for surf rescues. It's got lifesaving equipment like surf boards on it. And they drive down to the beach. Sam heads straight into the water, but from there, he can't see the kids anymore. The waves are too high. So he starts swimming in the direction of where he'd seen them from above.
然后他和另外大约七八个消防员跳上一辆专门用于冲浪救援的皮卡车后座。上面有救生板之类的救生设备。他们开车下到海滩。萨姆径直走进水里，但从那儿，他看不见孩子们了。海浪太高了。所以他开始朝他刚才从上面看到的方位游过去。
I didn't realize that as I was getting into the water, that my captain, who had gotten to a higher perch, was screaming at us to not go in the water.
我不知道当我走进水里时，我的队长，他到了更高的位置，正在尖叫着让我们别下水。
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
I didn't realize that he was yelling at us. And luckily, I didn't hear him because I might not have gone.
我不知道他在对我们喊。幸运的是我没听见他，因为我可能就不去了。
Why was he saying don't go in the water, though?
那他为什么说别下水呢？
He saw how far out that the people had gotten sucked out into the channel, and he thought it was too dangerous for us to--
他看到那些人被冲到了海峡多远的地方，他觉得对我们来说太危险了——
I see.
我明白了。
--go out there. It was too far of a swim for us. So I swim out there. And the first person that I see is this kid, who he looks like 13, 14, maybe 15 years old. And he's bobbing up and down by the rocks. It looked like he was trying to get out. And I'm like, hey, are you OK? And he said, ah, I'm stuck. It's like, OK. Grab onto this. We throw him a little floaty device that we swim with, like the things you see on Baywatch that the lifeguards carry.
——去那里。对我们来说游得太远了。所以我游过去了。我看到的第一个人是这个孩子，他看起来13、14，可能15岁。他在岩石旁边上下浮动。看起来他正试图出来。我说，嘿，你还好吗？他说，啊，我被困住了。我说，好了。抓住这个。我们扔给他一个我们游泳时带着的小漂浮装置，就像你在《海滩救护队》里看到救生员带的那种东西。
Yeah.
是的。
So we throw him the device and pull him away from the rocks. And I'm like, hey, what happened? And he's like, oh, these two girls were in, and I tried to get in to help them out. And I was like, oh, so there are two more people. He's like, yeah. I was like, OK, where did they go? And he's like, they went that way. So he just pointed out--
所以我们扔给他装置，把他拉离岩石。我说，嘿，发生什么了？他说，噢，那两个女孩进去了，我试图进去帮她们。我说，噢，所以还有两个人。他说，是的。我说，好的，她们去哪了？他说，她们去那边了。所以他只是指着——
Which way did he point?
他指向哪个方向？
He pointed to the open ocean, and I couldn't see shit. So I'm like, OK. Now I'm calculating in my mind, I can't see where these people are. I've got one patient with me. I can't just leave him. What do I do?
他指向了开阔的海洋，我什么都没看见。所以我说，好了。现在我在脑子里计算，我看不见这些人在哪。我身边有一个病人。我不能就把他留下。我该怎么办？
Two other rescuers swim up at that moment and take over. They may be 100 yards out at this point. Sam starts swimming into the open ocean. He's swimming and swimming and swimming. He's getting tired, a little scared.
另外两个救援人员在那一刻游了过来并接手了。这时他们可能离岸边100码了。萨姆开始游向开阔的海洋。他不停地游啊游啊游。他累了，有点害怕。
And now, I'm like, man, I'm getting pretty far out here and thinking about trying to make it back in. And then I see one of my co-workers, who is a really good surfer and a good swimmer. And he's booking it on this surfboard. And I figured, obviously, he can see something that I can't, and I just change my angle to that line. It was him and another guy out there. And we all kind of get out there, and they found the two girls. So, one of them was in the water, still with their head above water. She was treading water OK. And the other one wasn't there anymore. And one of them reached down and grabbed her as she was sinking underwater.
现在，我想，伙计，我游得太远了，正在考虑试着游回来。然后我看到了我的同事，他是个很棒的冲浪者和游泳健将。他正骑着冲浪板飞驰。我想，很明显，他能看到我看不见的东西，我就改变角度游向那条路线。就是他和另一个家伙在那儿。我们都到了那儿，他们找到了那两个女孩。所以，其中一个在水里，头还在水面上。她踩水踩得还可以。另一个已经不见了。其中一个人伸手抓住她，她正在沉入水下。
It's a very weird situation because you don't know how long she's been under. So you just have this fear-- not fear, but this picture in your head of how bad it could be.
这是个非常奇怪的情况，因为你不知道她在水下待了多久。所以你心里只有恐惧——不是恐惧，而是你脑子里有幅画面，情况可能有多糟糕。
The girl's lips were blue. She wasn't breathing, wasn't conscious.
那个女孩的嘴唇发青。她没呼吸，没知觉。
And we pull her onto the board. We have this technique where we flip them onto the board and so she's out of the water. She's on the surfboard, the rescue board. And she's not breathing. We do some-- trying to do CPR in the water when you're just--
我们把她拉上板子。我们有一种技术，就是把她们翻到板子上，这样她就出了水面。她在冲浪板上，救援板上。她没呼吸。我们做了些——尝试在水里做心肺复苏，当你只是——
Geez.
天呐。
--treading water is ridiculous. It's not very effective.
——在踩水时简直不可思议。不是很有效。
So you and your friend are in the water, and she's on the board. And you're doing CPR from the water?
所以你和你的朋友在水里，她在板子上。你们在水里做心肺复苏？
Yeah, we're trying.
是的，我们在尝试。
Whoa.
哇。
So it's really a team effort on having people stabilize the board while other people are trying to bob up and push down on CPR and then bob back down under the water. I mean, you're almost like--
所以这真的是团队合作，有人稳定板子，而其他人试图上下浮动，按压胸部，然后再沉回水下。我的意思是，你几乎就像是——
Oh my God.
天呐。
--trying to propel yourself up out of the water to try and get some leverage and do some effective CPR.
——试图让自己浮出水面，以获得一些杠杆作用，进行有效的心肺复苏。
CPR, after all, involves pressing down hard on someone's chest. But they're not above her. They're in the water next to the surfboard, bobbing up and down.
心肺复苏，毕竟包括在某人的胸部用力按压。但他们不在她上方。他们在水里，在冲浪板旁边，上下浮动。
Yeah, you're out in the middle of the ocean-- not the middle of the ocean. But you're way, way far away from the shore. You can't see the shore anymore. And you're focused on the patient. You're like, all right, how do I get this person to breathe again? And somehow, she just started coughing up all that water. And I just remember the heaving, just the whole-- all the muscles just contracting and just the disgusting heaving and coughing of all this water coming up, up out of her mouth. And you're just like, holy shit. This is real.
是的，你在海洋中央——不是海洋中央。但你离岸边非常非常远。你已经看不见岸边了。你专注于病人。你心想，好吧，我怎么才能让她重新呼吸？不知何故，她开始咳出所有的水。我只记得那种起伏，整个——所有的肌肉都在收缩，嘴里咳出水的恶心画面。你就像是，圣屎啊。这是真的。
So now both girls are on surfboards. Sam says they were probably 1,000 yards out from the shore at that point, a current pulling them further and further from shore.
所以现在两个女孩都在冲浪板上了。萨姆说她们那时可能离岸边有1000码远，海流把她们拉得离岸边越来越远。
This is something I'll never forget, just sitting in the water there and having this person who I don't know vigorously cough into my face. And I don't have a mask on, and she doesn't have a mask on, because we're in the ocean. There's no mask in the ocean. And I just remember thinking, man. I really hope she doesn't have COVID.
这是我永远不会忘记的，只是坐在水里，有个我不认识的人对着我的脸用力咳嗽。我没戴口罩，她也没戴，因为我们在海洋里。海洋里没口罩。我只记得我在想，伙计。我真希望她没得新冠。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And it's like, there's so many other things to be thinking about right now. Like, this person almost drowned, and we're still in a dangerous position. We're getting sucked out into the shipping lane. I can't see the beach anymore. I don't know where we are. I don't know who's going to come get us.
就像，现在有很多别的事要考虑。比如，这个人差点淹死，而我们仍处于危险境地。我们正被吸进航道里。我看不见海滩了。我不知道我们在哪。我不知道谁会来接我们。
Oh my God.
天呐。
I'll try not to get eaten by a shark. I don't know.
我试着不被鲨鱼吃了。不知道。
Right. Literally, right? There's sharks there.
没错。字面上，对吧？那儿有鲨鱼。
Yeah, I mean, there's a ton of sharks out there, especially in the deep water, where we're getting sucked out to. And so, I'm just amazed at myself thinking about COVID in a situation like this, you know?
是的，我的意思是，那儿有很多鲨鱼，尤其是在深水区，我们正被吸进去的地方。所以我很惊讶自己在这种情况下还在想新冠，你知道吗？
And I'll never forget looking over to my coworker. And we just kind of looked at each other as she's coughing in our face. And I can see it all over his face, too. And we just had that nonverbal communication, where we're both like, oh, damn.
我永远不会忘记看着我的同事。当她对着我们的脸咳嗽时，我们只是看着对方。我能从他的脸上看出所有这一切。我们只是进行了非语言交流，我们都觉得，噢，该死。
I can't imagine anything that's more pandemic 2020 than being swept out to sea in shark-infested water and still not being able to escape the anxiety of COVID.
我无法想象有什么比被卷入鲨鱼出没的海水，却依然无法逃脱新冠焦虑更具2020疫情特色的了。
Seriously, right? I mean, that was like-- we've had plenty of surf rescues and cliff rescues before, but this COVID thing is new. And it's the difficulty of calls and the stress of calls is much higher than normal. I mean, you could have had 30 calls a year ago. And it would be less stressful than having 15 calls in this new COVID era.
真的，对吧？我的意思是，那就像——我们以前有过很多次冲浪救援和悬崖救援，但这个新冠事情是新的。呼叫的难度和压力比平时高得多。我的意思是，一年前你可能会有30次呼叫。而那会比在这个新冠新时代有15次呼叫压力小。
The kids were OK, by the way, and Sam didn't get COVID. But for so many of us, the specter of COVID is always peering over our shoulders, intensifying everything we do, from the most extreme activities-- the surf rescue, a cliff rescue-- to the most banal-- grocery shopping, a teeth cleaning. That anxiety is the ether we exist in now.
顺便说一句，孩子们没事，萨姆也没得新冠。但对我们许多人来说，新冠的幽灵总是徘徊在我们的肩膀之上，强化我们所做的一切，从最极端的活动——冲浪救援、悬崖救援——到最平庸的——买杂货、洗牙。那种焦虑是我们现在生存的以太。
There is one thing that's given Sam some comfort recently-- the vaccine. A few weeks ago, he had his second dose. He said it lifted a lot of stress for him. Now he only has to deal with fires, sharks, cliffs, people who've stopped breathing-- you know, regular work stuff.
最近有件事给了萨姆一些安慰——疫苗。几周前，他打了第二针。他说这为他减轻了很多压力。现在他只需要处理火灾、鲨鱼、悬崖、呼吸停止的人——你知道，常规工作。
Dana Chivvis is one of the producers of our show.
达纳·奇维斯是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Four, Boiling Under. So lots of things can go unspoken between family members, sometimes for years, sometimes forever. And we had this idea that it would be interesting to do a story where a parent talks to their grown-up kid about something the parent wanted to talk about for a while but never had. And we recorded a couple of these with different families. And the one that was the most interesting was this one.
第四幕，水下沸腾。所以家庭成员之间有很多话是没说出口的，有时多年，有时永远。我们有一个想法，做一个故事会很有趣，家长和成年的孩子谈论家长想谈很久但从未谈过的事情。我们录了一些不同家庭的对话。其中最有趣的是这一段。
This is weirdly-- I'm very nervous about this, dad.
这真的很奇怪——我对此非常紧张，爸。
I am, too, to a degree.
在某种程度上，我也是。
This is Chris Gethard and his dad, Ken Gethard.
这是克里斯·盖萨德和他父亲肯·盖萨德。
Because you and I don't really-- we have a really good relationship. We don't sit down and have personal conversations that often, though.
因为你和我并没有真正——我们关系真的很好。但我们不常坐下来进行个人谈话。
Chris has been on our show now and then. He's a comedian. And his father wanted to talk to Chris about Chris's depression. Chris has depression. He's talked about it on stage and on his podcast. He did a one-man show on HBO about it, which makes his dad feel bad, probably because Chris is talking publicly about stuff that the two of them have never really discussed.
克里斯偶尔会出现在我们的节目里。他是个喜剧演员。他父亲想和克里斯谈谈克里斯的抑郁症。克里斯有抑郁症。他在舞台上和他的播客里谈论过它。他在HBO做了一个关于它的单人秀，这让他的父亲感觉不太好，可能是因为克里斯正在公开谈论两人从未真正讨论过的事情。
Chris didn't reveal his depression to his parents until he was in his early 20s and had an incident where he nearly died. And then a friend, more or less, forced him to tell his family. And his dad had questions about all that. Chris came into the studio having no idea what his dad wanted to ask about. And they sat down. And I don't know, maybe we should have expected this. His dad didn't just jump right in with the stuff that he wanted to talk about. That's too heavy.
克里斯直到20多岁才向父母透露他的抑郁症，当时他发生了一起差点丧命的事件。然后一个朋友，或多或少，强迫他告诉家人。他父亲对这一切有很多疑问。克里斯来到演播室，完全不知道他父亲想问什么。他们坐了下来。我不知道，也许我们早该料到这一点。他父亲并没直接切入他想谈的事情。那太沉重了。
Well, the first one is actually a question from mom.
好吧，第一个其实是你妈的问题。
Oh, OK.
噢，好的。
Do you pray?
你祈祷吗？
Ken asked Chris about pro wrestling. He asked about sports.
肯问了克里斯关于职业摔跤的事。他问了体育运动。
And I'm just-- why are you-- why are you such an NBA fan, rather than a pro baseball fan?
而且我只是——为什么你——为什么你是个NBA球迷，而不是职业棒球迷？
They talked about their old neighborhood in New Jersey. Ken told Chris how much he hates celebrity endorsements. Would Chris ever do a celebrity endorsement? Would Chris ever do a sex scene in a movie, a nude scene in a movie? This continued for an hour. And then finally--
他们谈到了他们在新泽西的老街区。肯告诉克里斯他有多讨厌名人代言。克里斯会做名人代言吗？克里斯会在电影里做性爱场景、裸体场景吗？这持续了一个小时。然后最后——
Hey listen, there's a couple questions I definitely do want to hit. So let's go to them. I don't want to run out of time.
嘿，听着，有些问题我绝对想聊聊。所以我们去问吧。我不想时间不够。
Sure.
好的。
So--
那么——
And then Ken brought up Chris's depression. He wanted to know why Chris took so long to tell his parents about it.
然后肯提到了克里斯的抑郁症。他想知道为什么克里斯花了那么长时间才告诉父母这件事。
Well, when you finally told mom-- and that was, what, towards the end of college--
嗯，当你最终告诉妈妈时——那是，什么，大学快结束时？
Yeah.
是的。
--I guess that was?
我想那是吗？
Yeah, I think that was.
是的，我想是那样。
Absolutely floored us. I mean, we had zero clue.
彻底击垮了我们。我是说，我们一无所知。
Yeah.
是的。
And on one hand, we're like the guilt. We got to protect you. Why couldn't we see this? But on the other hand, it's like, why didn't he come to us? Even now, you're like that, Chris. There was something on the web a couple of years ago was something. This is what I look like on a bad day, when I'm feeling depressed.
一方面，我们觉得有内疚感。我们得保护你。为什么我们看不出来？但另一方面，就像是，为什么他不来找我们？即使现在，你也是那样，克里斯。几年前网上有东西……这是我感觉抑郁时，糟糕的一天的样子。
Yeah.
是的。
And you said something to the effect, I'll tell my wife, I'll tell my brother, but I'll never let my parents see me like this. And that was after we've known. So even then, now, it's like sticking out there.
你说过大概这样的话，我会告诉我的妻子，告诉我的兄弟，但我绝不会让父母看到我这样。那是在我们知道之后。所以即使是现在，它就像是悬在那儿。
Yeah, I don't know why. I don't know. I guess, it would make me feel like I was letting you guys down in some way or failing in some way. I don't know. I don't know.
是的，我不知道为什么。我不知道。我想，这会让我觉得我在某种程度上让你们失望了，或者失败了。我不知道。我不知道为什么。
Yeah, but mom and I would be the first two there to help you and do whatever it took to--
是的，但妈妈和我本来会是头两个来帮助你，不惜一切代价——
I know.
我知道。
--protect you.
——保护你。
I don't know why I've never been comfortable with you guys seeing me like that or knowing that side of me so well. But I just felt like it was a thing to hide. I don't know. I don't know why. I don't know why. Because you guys did-- as soon as I told you, it was like everyone went into this mode where I was so supported. And I had always assumed that if I ever told anybody about it, I was going to be on my own. Whereas when I kind of hit rock bottom and started talking to you guys about it, it was like instantaneously the safest I ever felt.
我不知道为什么我从没适应你们看到我这样，或者了解我的那一面。但我只是觉得那是该隐藏的事。我不知道。我不知道为什么。因为你们——当我告诉你们时，每个人都进入了那种模式，我得到了巨大的支持。我一直假设如果我告诉任何人，我就得独自一人。而当我触底并开始和你们谈论它时，那是我感觉最安全的一瞬间。
Yeah. Well, I'm glad you felt that way, but I hope you understand where I'm coming from on this, too.
是的。嗯，我很高兴你有那种感觉，但我希望你也理解我的立场。
Yeah, no, I wish I talked to you guys about it sooner. I wish.
是的，不，我希望我能早点和你们谈这个。我希望。
And you did a fantastic job of hiding it from mom and I, which I have all amounts of guilt over--
你对我和妈妈隐藏得非常好，这让我感到极度的内疚——
No--
不——
--till my dying day.
——直到我死的那天。
--you don't have to. You don't have that many guilts over that. I mean, I was so good at hiding it, so good at hiding it. And I don't know why. I don't know why I never let you and mom know about that. It's just not my instinct. My instinct is that that's going to worry you guys so much, and you're going to have to sit around and then be scared about me, and I don't want you doing that. And I always figured maybe I could push through it, or it would pass. Or even I felt like maybe I'm just a moody kid.
——你不必那样。你没那么多内疚感。我是说，我太擅长隐藏它了，太擅长隐藏它了。我不知道为什么。我不知道为什么我从没让你们了解。那不是我的直觉。我的直觉是这会让你非常担心，你们得坐下来担心我，我不想你们那样。我一直想也许我能挺过去，或者它会过去。甚至我觉得也许我只是个喜怒无常的孩子。
Yeah, if you're feeling bad, you need help and stuff like that, Chris, I would like you to come to us at any point in time. But I'm not a professional. I don't know what to tell you. I don't know if I'm making sense. I want to be there, but I don't want to tell you something wrong either. That's always in the back of my head. It's like, oh God, if he comes to me-- you know.
是的，如果你感觉不好，你需要帮助，诸如此类，克里斯，我希望你在任何时候来找我们。但我不是专业人士。我不知道该告诉你什么。我不知道我是否说得对。我想在那里，但我也不想告诉你错误的东西。这总是在我的脑后。就像，噢，天哪，如果他来找我——你知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Am I going to tell him something, and all of a sudden, he's going to be worse?
我是不是要告诉他什么，然后突然间，他变得更糟了？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm scared. I don't think I want you coming to me-- dad, I'm upset. I need you to talk me. I wouldn't know what to say. That's what you have a professional for, you know? And it's-- does that make sense anywhere there?
我很害怕。我不觉得我想要你来找我——爸，我很沮丧。我需要你跟我说话。我不知道该说什么。那是专业人士做的事，你知道吗？这——哪一点有道理吗？
Yeah. No, because I know that. I know that's the truth. I know that's the truth. I know you're not the guy to talk about that. It's part of what made it very hard to say it. But it doesn't-- I think I let that fear make me not talk to you about it. Whereas what really happened is exactly what I should have known you would have done, which was you're not the guy to talk about it, but you're certainly going to make sure that I find the person--
是的。不，因为我知道。我知道那是事实。我知道那是事实。我知道你不是谈论那个的人。这部分使得很难说出口。但这并不——我觉得我让那个恐惧使我没和你们谈。而真正发生的是我早就应该知道你们会做的，也就是你不是谈论那个的人，但你绝对会确保我找到那个人——
I'm going to get you to the right person, yeah.
我会把你送到正确的人那儿，是的。
You're going to get me there. You're going to-- I mean, that's one of the things I regret the most, is like, you're not the guy-- you were never going to be the guy who I could come to and say, dad, I'm really sad, and I don't know why. You weren't going to know what to say, but I should have given a lot more credit to knowing you were going to run through a wall to get me where I needed to go.
你会把我送去那儿。你会——我是说，我最后悔的一件事是，你不是那个人——你永远不会是那个我可以来找他说，爸，我很伤心，但我不知道为什么的人。你不会知道该说什么，但我应该给予更多信任，我知道你会冲破墙壁把我送到我需要去的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
Chris Gethard and his dad, Ken Gethard. Thanks to them for agreeing to have this conversation on tape. The story first ran on our show a few years back. Chris is the host of the long running podcast, Beautiful Anonymous.
克里斯·盖萨德和他父亲肯·盖萨德。感谢他们同意录下这次谈话。这个故事几年前首次在我们的节目播出。克里斯是长青播客《美丽的匿名者》的主持人。
[MUSIC - "JUST UNDER THE SURFACE" BY VENICE]
[音乐 - 威尼斯的《水下》]
Our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put our show together today include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ari Saperstein, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior editor, David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor, Emanuele Berry.
我们今天的节目由艾薇娃·德科恩菲尔德制作。今天参与制作我们节目的人包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、托宾·洛、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、阿里·萨珀斯坦、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑，戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑，埃马纽埃尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Gabriela Munoz, Christopher Brown, and the folks at El Camino Hospital for letting us record vaccinations, Mickey Capper, Adam VanGerpen, Dan Casey, Karissa Reinach, and Chuck Leung. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's lists of favorite shows, videos we've made over the year, links to our TV program, tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢加布里埃拉·穆尼奥斯、克里斯托弗·布朗，以及埃尔卡米诺医院的员工让我们录制疫苗接种过程，米奇·卡珀、亚当·范格彭、丹·凯西、卡丽莎·雷纳克和查克·梁。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，你可以免费在线收听我们超过700集的档案。此外，那里还有最喜欢的节目列表、我们多年制作的视频、通往电视节目的链接，以及大量其他内容。再次强调，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. In his early career, he was a writer in The Flintstones. They were scripting some lines for Bam Bam one day, and one of the other writers said, hey, how about this? Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. Torey couldn't help himself, adding his little stamp to it.
《美国生活》通过公共广播交流中心 PRX 分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。他职业生涯早期是《摩登原始人》的编剧。有一天他们在给班班写台词，另一个编剧说，嘿，这个怎么样？班，班，班，班，班，班……托瑞忍不住了，给它加了自己的印记。
And then, bam, there you go. It's done.
然后，砰，好了，结束了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "JUST UNDER THE SURFACE" BY VENICE]
[音乐 - 威尼斯的《水下》]